actors are a different beast
they
behave differently than everyone else on
set
it's like they're like the popular kids
in high school
so the first one was being able to think
on your feet you said and then the
second skill a good director should have
is
just being very proficient with editing
yes really understanding editing i think
the third skill and this i'd say is
number one and
it's knowing how to work with actors and
i am
continually shocked at
how that is a skill that most directors
don't seem to know i don't understand
why that one is the
[Music]
one that's shoved aside
just today a friend of mine who's a dp
said that um
she said
they're working with an actor the lead
of this movie and the lead is not good
and i said
well hopefully your director
can
direct the actor and and
bring up a good performance and he said
or she said
no the director's giving no notes
whatsoever
like he's
he's working with the camera department
and the actors left on their own the
amount of time is unbelievable the
amount of times i hear actors complain
about this
i went out there i'm doing my thing i'm
getting no notes i have no idea what i'm
doing you know if you understand what
it's like to be an actor it's like
painting blindfolded you're out there
performing but you can't see it
and if your director is hiding in video
village back there
not telling you
that is a it's a very
it's a very frustrating place to be as
an actor
and
it just astounds me that more directors
don't spend more time learning the skill
and it seems to be this
terror when it comes to it
this idea that working with an actor is
scary
i'm not sure where that
idea comes from
i worked with an actor i was rather a
director friend of mine
a couple years ago was helping her out
on set and
she said
she said i heard her say this is someone
else she goes
well this actor has worked with martin
scorsese what do i have to say i'm like
what do you mean what do you have you're
the director
they want to hear what you have to say
it doesn't they don't care
that you are not martin scorsese they
just need to know what you want
so
the most common excuse i hear from
directors when it comes to this kind of
subject is they always say
that oh well just cast the right person
and that will solve your problems well
first of all i think that's a terrible
uh
philosophy to have because what that is
saying is
well i'm just gonna make sure that i'm
going to hire the right person so that
they can do the hard work
that's taking all of the pressure off of
you and throwing it on someone else so
that you can just get out of actually
preparing and learning how to do it
second of all it's completely
unrealistic
do you know how many
projects there are when you're working
on something you were always going to
have the one person that you didn't cast
the the the
i was working on a commercial one time
and uh i picked this act i thought this
actor was really good and they had this
great presence to them the client said
no we want this other guy
and i was like
i don't think this guy has any
experience i think he's kind of new
and in his audition
he didn't even read the lines
they cast him because of his look
so he gets set
so i have no choice
this is the guy i have to work with
um he shows up and sure enough it was
his first time on set all right so
now the philosophy of
just cast the right people suddenly
that's gone and now what are you gonna
do
well what are you gonna do so
i mean the amount of films that are made
where the investor says hey i'll give
you the money for your movie but i'm
gonna put my daughter in the lead
has your daughter ever acted well no but
you got a movie and you just have to
make my daughter look good okay so then
how do you do it how do you work with
the actor oh oh no the actor they're so
scary
um
actors are a different beast
they
behave differently than everyone else on
set
it's like they're like the popular kids
in high school
they're you know what i mean and you're
the nerd the dork sitting there at the
lush table and you know whoever walks in
and they're like they're charming and
everyone likes them and they're so
pretty and everyone just wants to be be
them or be with them that's the actors
are like that that's why we always point
the cameras at them you know because
they have that charm and they have that
look
so it can feel like you're the dork in
high school who's got to go up and now
you're going to talk to this person and
tell them what to do
and they're going to listen why would
they listen to me who am i
so
that's the feeling often times that you
can get
well the reality is they're a person
and oftentimes i find that
especially when they can be difficult to
work with it's because they're terrified
they're
they're just a person they happen to be
blessed with this beautiful outer shell
a lot of the time
but that doesn't mean they don't have
insecurities as well
and the more they're left on their own
without any direction the more insecure
they can feel i mean think about what
that must be like if you you go out
there and you do your scene and no one
says anything to you
and you have just bared your soul
in some
scene and no one's going good job or
whatever like that that
that might even frustrate you make you
angry well with good reason right i mean
it's like working for any boss and the
boss is never telling you if you're
doing good work
never encouraging you never to i mean it
would be very frustrating place to be so
understanding that they are just a human
and it's so funny because i
oftentimes i'll come up
actor will come up on on set
i'll walk up to them and i can see them
trembling
like
if i'm you know and it's weird because
i'll be at my director's chair and
talking to the dp and we're doing this
over here da da and i look and there's
the actor and they come in and oh
they're pretty and
and i walk up and i see him kind of
shaking it's like wow i never saw that
until i actually walked up and made that
connection so
the lesson there is i think really
making sure that they're recognized and
that they are um
welcomed and feel safe that is so
important to do to
because what we're asking of an actor
think about this in the in the grand
scheme of a
set if you're a cinematographer they're
not
they are um operating a piece of
machinery they're bringing their
artistry to it no question
they're creating emotion with this
camera painting with light
but they're not
being vulnerable
they may be even if they are scared
you're never going to see it because
they're behind the lens you know
same with the gaffer same with a
sound guy and a wardrobe person they i
mean if they're having a bad day they
could go and cry in their trailer you
know
behind closed doors
you never can see that an actor they're
they're naked in front of the enti and
everything that you've been building for
years with the script and
everything is pointing at them the
camera is pointing right
that's a lot of stress on a person so
when you see them walk in
you're in high school a popular kid
walks in
it can be the hardest thing to do to
walk up and just say hey how you doing
everything okay just check in and make
sure they're all right that is a huge
move and that will be
think about it making them feel welcome
and comfortable even though it looks
like they may not need that do it anyway
that is a huge thing that will help you
actors as well
simply and it sounds so simple to say
but they just want to know what you want
if you don't know
what you want
tell them
because
this is where you can invite them into
your own space
in storytelling you can say
this is a goodbye scene but i'm not sure
it needs to be a weepy one
you know
and have a dialogue with them about it
because that's where the fun can begin
where you're actually going
you're saying goodbye to someone who
you've been best friends with for years
but they've always been mean to you
would you really be crying as you say
like what
and you can start to play well what if
it's
triumphant goodbye what if it's and
that's where it could be really fun now
you're going to start to see the actor
come alive because they are being
allowed to
play with you and you know you're on the
same team
that can really be a lot of fun
um
i also think that
as a as a director
what we do because you know because
we've been thinking about this story for
longer than anybody else on the team
like they're longer than the dp the
wardrobe person we've been in
working with this story forever
and so it's very easy to
and necessary in a lot of ways to come
in with your own ideas about how the
scene should look and yes that's
important
but
you want to leave a little room for
surprise you want to leave a little room
for them to bring what they have to the
table
and you would do that you do that in
every other department right you you're
you're going to tell the dp
i just want this to look like
you know like the whole films from the
70s how they kind of had this rich color
grain
kind of looking for that kind of rich
color grain in this kind of thing and
i'm thinking it's all shot on long
lenses and the dp may go yeah but you
know in that time
those kind of lenses didn't exist they
did a lot of zooms
instead of dollies so what if we did it
more zoomy lenses oh yeah that's right
that's right how cool is that that's you
creating together that's you allowing
the dp to kind of bring his artistry or
her artistry to the table
do the same with an actor
i find it really enjoyable process when
they come to set
they've been working their lines by
themselves or with their
husband or wife
or or sometimes even just a recorder
they're they record it they have a
certain way they want to do the lines
well let them try it i think it's it can
really create the fun sandbox when
you're you bring the two or three actors
and have everyone pause the work let the
dp sit over here for a second and say
all right let's just walk through it a
second see what's what you got let me
see what you got let's just let's try it
boom walk through the scene
um
now they feel like
they've
brought something to the table you're
able to like okay that's cool let's use
this piece but i think what we want to
do is turn in this moment here and then
oh yeah yeah
now you're working together that really
allows them
a feeling like they've been heard
um
and that will just you could just you
can watch their anxiety just
go down
um
another big thing to remember with
actors is that when you're directing
this is super easy to do because you're
being hit with a thousand questions a
minute so
i mean it is
you just did a take the dp's like
are you sure it's okay with this lens
like this like i think maybe we go to a
tighter lens oh yeah okay good let's
swap to the hundred and do the blah blah
wardrobe person's like i don't know this
shirt looks kind of wrinkly
and oh yeah cool is that background prop
looking okay and you know everyone's
asking and the actor is standing there
on their mark
like
is that all right like and you're
all right let's do it again you totally
forget
that
they're out there
naked
wondering why we're doing it again and
it has nothing to do with them so
remembering
all right we need to do one more we got
to make a change on our end you're doing
just fine just keep doing that exactly
thing you're right in the right zone but
we got to change
something with the camera we've hit a
bobble on the cable whatever it is like
remembering that
it's like you're spinning plates on the
end of sticks
and the actors always on the end out
here and you'd think that they'd be the
easiest one to remember but that's the
first one usually most people forget is
that they're just standing out there on
their mark
you know waiting for someone to talk to
so just remembering to keep them engaged
i haven't forgotten about you you're
still there it's all good let's fix
something over here or whatever um
i think
yeah that that happened number of times
on the abandoned by the way where it was
the abandon is essentially one actor in
front of the camera the whole time
and a lot of these same rules applied
right so
the the premise of the abandon is a
soldier who's
hit with a bright light
when he's in the middle of a firefight
and he wakes up in this room with no
doors windows exits of any kind he can't
get a hold of anybody
and the whole movie is him trying to
escape this mystery room well that means
he's in the only guy in front of the
camera the whole time that's an
incredible vulnerable place to be
the the actor that is like
it was his first lead in a movie
and
you know that's that's that's terrifying
i don't i wouldn't want that position
like if i were a lead in a film that's
scary enough but the fact that you're
the only face we're gonna see
in this whole movie oh my gosh
it was so important to take the time to
make sure he was okay
just greet him every day on set see
check in see how he was feeling you know
making sure he's comfortable
go through it let him try a couple takes
to see what he you know all of these
same kinds of things
then
with him specifically
there were a couple times where we would
have some bumps in the road and this
this leads me to a huge point
i made a couple mistakes
um
there was a day where
we were doing some
stunt sequences and and ironically the
moment i'm talking about is in the
trailer
there's a moment where
the character realizes that something is
very wrong oh no the big discovery is
being made and he goes oh my god we were
trying to do this
very specific shot where the camera was
going to do this big dolly push and it
it's tilting as it goes
and he's
leaning on the wall a certain kind of
way
and i'm
and the way the film is put together we
had this camera that could do this it's
called a lambda head so we could tilt it
and and the film plays with gravity a
lot so we would always tilt the lambda
head oftentimes to make it look like
gravity was coming from the wrong
direction but when you look at the lens
and then you look at the stage it looks
ridiculous because the he's oftentimes
standing at a tilt and it's like i would
start chuckling because it's like i feel
like i'm making star trek in 1960
because it's just like people throwing
themselves around so i'm just like kind
of
chuckling at the
hilarity of it all
and i'm trying to get this very real
moment for him
the cinematographer wasn't feeling well
that day
and i'm trying to get this shot we were
all
this is like three quarters of the way
through the shoot we're all completely
exhausted
and i'm giggling at the monitor well
here's the actor
all he knows is that people are looking
at him on screen and laughing
right
so
understandably so
he was
feeling extremely insecure and got mad
at me it's a dude
i feel like
my ass is hanging in the wind out here
you know
and i and i
he said i think you're laughing at me
and i realize in that moment
that
of course he would feel that way of
course he would think that he has no
idea the context of where i'm coming
from but
the poor guy you know
is understandably frustrated with me so
the point i'm trying to make is these
things are gonna happen you know
miscommunications happen
you're gonna snap sometimes you're gonna
say something that you didn't mean
that's gonna hurt somebody's feelings
and it's so important to own up to it
to you know after that day
i actually had to
we had he and i had a long long talk
about like hey man
i never meant to humiliate you that is
was never my intent and i did not mean
for it to come out i was laughing at
something totally different just
the comical nature of what we do for a
living was really more
of what i was thought was so funny at
the time um it was nothing to do with
how stupid you looked no i would never
laugh at something like that like i'm
here to protect you
but i had to come forward it was very
difficult you know i had to tell him and
be very honest and really protect him in
that moment this happens a lot you know
if you find that you snapped at your
actors some way because they
irritated you and you did it in front of
everybody
it's a good idea to pull them aside
after that or the next day or whatever
and say hey
that was out of line
what that's going to do is
that's going to do this
you're going to be as vulnerable as
they're we're asking them to be and it's
going to put you on this even level with
them where you're both hey we're human
we're trying to do this thing there's a
lot of pressure the sun is going down
we're running out of time
i snapped i'm sorry can we get past this
and just
i'll try to do better next time that's
such a big um
really i think important move to do to
be willing to do that
that'll help you with actors quite a bit
usually if you are that vulnerable with
them
their performance will go up because
they know that it's safe
they know that you're all working
together trying to do the same kind of
thing and they once they are vulnerable
vulnerability with an actor
is the secret sauce to good performance
because that is what this is why this
what makes them different this is what
when you see denzel washington
performing what you're seeing that's so
incredible is he's so open
he's you are seeing
the inner workings the inner terror the
little soul in there
that's what's so interesting that's what
makes us all lean into the screen that's
that's what draws us in it's these it's
these while people who behave like that
generally become actors who are used to
exposing themselves like that
that that's not normal that's not what
normal humans do
that's what makes them so interesting to
watch that's what we need but in order
to see that you have to make them feel
safe feel comfortable they want to see
vulnerability in you
it's a relationship
so